ich will dass sie nicht entdecken
für team nord beginnt der wettbewerb in
schleswig holstein
genaugenommen mitten auf dem meer die
drei sind auf dem weg zur
nordfriesischen insel pellworm abwarten
noch ist das wattenmeer ruhig aber das
kann sich ändern
hier eine durchsage eric nicole und
allmendinger bitte auf die grafik
findet klug nutzen mithilfe der
folgenden geokoordinaten das kann das
gps gerät auch nicht beantworten
aber es kennt den weg für die drei
beginnt eine schnitzeljagd über die
insel pellworm mit dem gps gerät kommt
team nord nicht weiter vielleicht hilft
ja fragen sie sind hier im
wattenmeerhaus von pellworm
hier erfahren die drei was das
eigentlich ist dieses wattenmeer die
insel pellworm befindet sich mitten im
wattenmeer das heißt es ist das mehr
dass wir ab und zu frei gespielt und
dann ist kein wasser mehr da sondern
rundherum ist nur noch land zu sehen die
flut kommt was als sechs stunden lang
geht das wasser sechs stunden lang kommt
das wasser aber nirgendwo ist knut
dabei hat die insel nur wenige bewohner
gegen 17 uhr gewartet die fällige
waldeck nun klug nutzt hat die der
geburt wieder nichts
hoffentlich kann klug nutzen nicht nur
plattdeutsch sondern auch hochdeutsch
tschuldigung dance oder haben sie glück
das bin ich
weitere informationen für uns jetzt
kommt die zweite aufgabe stellt zusammen
mit briefträger klug nutzen die post an
folgende geokoordinaten zu
da muss man durch
in eineinhalb stunden niedrig versorgen
wenn man jetzt los läuft dann könnte man
das noch gerade schaffen knut nutzen ist
nicht nur postbote er arbeitet auch beim
küstenschutz hier repariert und wartet
der deiche
das sind hohe erdwälle die das festland
bei flut schützen
es gibt eine unwetterwarnung zum glück
begleitet klug das team ungefähr sieben
kilometer lang ist die strecke bis zur
hallig syke
der wind wird immer stärker
nicole modena und ehre kommt nur noch
langsam voran
und dann passiert ist die flut setzt ein
das wasser kommt zurück
selbst dem erfahrenen nordfriesen wird
es zu gefährlich wäre jetzt nur noch
eine runde laufen und das wird mir nicht
schaffen würde
das ist noch ein ganzes endlichen
verletzt bevor wir dann wieder zurück
zumindest das wetter hier alle freuen
wir müssen zurück aber wenn sie jetzt
aufgeben ist das ticket weg das will vor
allem almut hähner nicht wahrhaben ich
schwimmen kann man trotzdem team nord
liegt 0 zu 1 2
bern
die
si